what are we talking about today
gina hi big ask mood hey everybody hey
we're
we're back with another episode of big
ask mood where
we answer your questions we went on
instagram and we told you to ask us
questions and we're to
answer them here today and we're going
to shout you out unless you want to be
not a mouse then we will not say your
name
excuse you oh hello
i'm trying to sit here this shelf
attacking
is ready to try it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay it's still gonna happen
again
yes nope hey don't get your ass over
here
you are riled up today woman i'm gonna
go home i'm so tired
i gotta put my earring back in good job
we're answering let me hold this for you
wait and there we go we're answering all
your questions that you wanted to ask us
because you know we like to do some like
some outreach in our community you know
and talk to you guys
we outreached on our instagram you know
at big mood girls if you want to submit
questions of your own you can find us on
instagram
so make sure you guys follow us to know
when we're asking you questions
all right ladies let's and gentlemen oh
sorry
ladies and gentlemen and gentlemen boys
let's get into it i'm gonna start with
the white one
first as usual okay i'm down as long as
it's not
do you pee pee out your butt hole in
your butthole sometimes
yes sometimes somebody likes that stupid
[ __ ]
this one i actually relate to this one
so well rj
asks what is the one question y'all are
tired of getting asked either
iran or online do you pee out your butt
where's david so oh for you [ __ ] i
don't know i'm not attached to him at
the hip just because we did a few videos
together
if you if you find where the food is
that's probably where david is
accurate i just never understood it's
like i i don't know how to answer that
because like sometimes i do meet and
greets
or like sometimes people just comment on
my instagram i'm like i don't know go to
his instagram
mine is uh when are you having kids i'm
[ __ ] i'm trying to have kids okay
i'm trying oh no for me it's why don't
you give casey a baby
baby why won't you give him a bite
no they even go as far as saying casey
should divorce you and get
with the woman who will give him a baby
you're being so selfish tiff
why don't you give him a bit go ask him
why hasn't he knocked me up
why haven't he given her a baby
it's not a christmas present through
this one box when you get a baby in it
yeah
baby that's how big that is that's true
the right question is why don't you
destroy your body for nine months never
sleep spend all your money
for a man yeah honestly that question
irks me so much because i'm like you
know i've had a child
you know yeah i'm trying yeah
you know there is a new variable here i
will say the people that are just like
hey i can't wait for you guys to have
kids i don't i don't mind that yeah
that's cute
yeah that's funny but there are some
mean ones like superman i'm talking
about the ones that she's talking about
where they're like
uh you're getting up there um time's a
ticking like your ovaries are going to
dry up if you don't have a kid soon i'm
like
people's god damn yeah
[Music]
stay out of my ovaries when it comes to
fertility business
right now like i learned like within the
last five years i didn't even know this
but you're not supposed to ask people
like so what are you having kids because
there's some people who can't have
children and that's such an
awkward you ever think about you know
fertility issues also
if if a woman looks pregnant never
assume she's pregnant oh my god yeah
sometimes they have a miscarriage in the
middle of the pregnancy
or the stillbirth is in there and then
they have to deal with they look
pregnant and people are constantly
asking them when the baby's coming
and it's very sad it happened to a girl
i know and it was really really [ __ ]
sad
so don't ask them about that yeah just
be like if they bring it up
cool but yeah but you don't bring it up
jesus don't do that i was pregnant i
i pretended like i made someone feel
really awkward
because i was a teen pregnant and then
they were like
oh when are you doing i was like i'm
just full
like i just had a big meal oh my gosh
i was such a [ __ ] i'm tired of people
asking me why i don't follow joe or
comment on his instagram anymore
oh my god people go into my dms every
week and they're like why don't you
follow joe on instagram
i don't understand why you think yeah
hello they broke hello
what the [ __ ] that's so weird that's
like going to your divorced parents and
be like
how come you don't call mom to say hi in
the morning anymore how come you don't
get why don't you send mom flowers
anymore know right
and it's over bro that's why stop asking
me even if it's an amicable breakup
which it was
yeah it it doesn't mean they have to
stay you think i want to see him every
day
no that's why i broke up with him i love
you joe
there's also like people are like oh so
gina you went to dubai are you an escort
and i was like
first of all [ __ ] do you think i would
be like
here right now if i was an escort yeah
i'll be making sure you're making way
more money than
[ __ ] pennies we're making high-class
horses and the weird thing is i went
once it was for a drift racing event
with a full team
of like a bunch of people and the funny
thing is
you know like they say the the
stereotype is instagram hoes they go
over there they get [ __ ] on by princes
and they get money and all that [ __ ]
who taught you that me i told you about
that because it was all over the
internet i said it on an episode of jk
and they're like okay well obviously
she's doing it why would i die myself
out you [ __ ] morons so people are
like
she's an escort i'm like damn i'm the
poorest escort ever
i must suck so bad at being
good enough not a good suck either like
i have to pay them as an apology if i if
i'm this poor as an escort
jesus christ i hate that when like
you're talking about something they're
like um you got some skeletons in your
closet
because it's like yeah i'm literally
talking about it because it's not
something i do it's something that i
heard of and it's crazy
or like remember that girl that i told
you guys that that is my girlfriend who
is an escort she's a very high class
escort
i'll tell stories about her and people
like she's obviously talking about her
own stories yeah
yeah feel like they want it to be real
so they could hire you gina it's
actually a compliment she broke [ __ ]
can't afford this [ __ ] are you kidding
me
or like um they're like well she knows
escorts and strippers so she was
obviously one
and it's like well no it's because i
lived a life of meeting all different
kinds of people and i traveled
i was go gangster i worked day jobs
night jobs whatever
i didn't sit in my basement all day and
only had like four friends on the
internet
you know like i knew a lot of different
people from all different kinds of walks
of life and that's what happens when you
you're outgoing and you make friends
even if you're not
going to make friends i still met a lot
of people like wow yeah interesting
character
exactly i just like to talk to people
and learn about their lives like
especially when they got something weird
going on
there's a lot of weirdos in l.a so
they're
yeah judging everyone i'm not in the
entertainment industry too whenever i go
to these functions i always
pick some random obscure thing i'm like
oh yeah me and my dad go and hunt
raccoons and we sell
hats at a farmer's market like we make
those hats
i'm just here by accident people are
just always like oh yeah or like
they say things like the stories are
made up i remember they said that about
me and david our stories are a lot of
made up oh yeah
yeah everyone would say all of his
stories were made up
yeah i'm not a boring [ __ ] like i go on
two things and the thing is
people in l.a are weird they are what
you hear it does sound made up
yeah the things that you hear also like
truth is stranger than fiction sometimes
comedians exaggerate and so sometimes
they'll be like well i think david
exaggerated a little bit in that one
story that one time
in the face every story after that
they're like is he exaggerating again
you know
oh cause sometimes it's just he's like
practicing stand-up material
yeah which is a little exaggerated but i
think people just are not
able to see outside of their own little
bubble that's true you know what i mean
like
it's weird out there bro no for me it's
uh like the annoying thing about getting
asked
either online or in real life is so
i've been on social media for many years
now i have
exposed a lot of very intimate private
details about my life
and there was one that would not leave
me alone for
so long luckily now it's it's not that
thing like not that relevant anymore
but i had mentioned on uh ask the feels
where i said that i mentioned like
putting a pillow on casey's face when we
have sex
and for the longest time people are like
free casey
remove the pillow like all these things
and i'm like
chill yeah yeah i was like he actually
enjoyed it too guys like
chill like it was fun don't yuck their
yums
it's so funny because like in the
beginning it's like all right it's
pretty funny because
you guys have you know you guys are
supporting us you guys are watching it
but after a while it gets kind of
uh-huh yeah yeah yeah yeah cause then it
gets to the point where i think they
because they you know you guys see us
and you hear all these details
you get to a point where you feel like
you really know us and like we're really
really tight like
real life friends tight and it's awesome
that you get to feel like that
from your perspective but we don't know
that perspective so then
when you come to us with with these kind
of comments or
in real life yeah come to us with these
comments it's like
whoa like we're not cool like that
because i don't even know you
but i understand
it's such a like a degrading thing for
casey because it's like as if he has no
autonomy he's not a man
he can't he can't like fix his
relationship himself like he's just
blind to the
environment that you've given him it's
so funny because they're trying to save
him but exactly it just ends up being
more inspiring
but i thought that was super insulting
too with joe because people were like oh
she's a gold digger
she's just using him blah blah blah but
i'm like do you really think that low of
joe that either
a that he wouldn't know that or like you
know like either he's
either a he's participating in knowing
that i'm a gold digger which i'm not
or b i'm not yeah do you not think that
you how dumb do you think he is right
like right
i know it's like it's like okay a part
of me is just like you know what the
fact that you guys are even
talking about us or even interacting you
should whatever awesome you guys are
still fans you guys are still hanging
out and that's awesome
but after a while it's just like it's
like working at a a
like a cashier right you're thankful you
have a job but when something
doesn't scan and the guy always goes
well he goes it's free right you're just
same like over and over she's [ __ ]
hilarious man never heard that one
before
i'm thankful to be here oh you know that
happened at chili's all the time
so i worked at chili's i was a hostess
when i started working there
and we had these little buzzers you know
so you wait for your table to be ready
and when you first hand it to them it
buzzes to show you what it's like
when your table's ready oh guess my
table's ready now every single
dad ever is like oh guess we're ready
i'm
all like [ __ ] jesus but speaking of
tiff i've had an experience before
because people you know they they see
our personalities online and
uh you know i interact with you guys
like this because you guys are like my
friends
yeah this is one girl that came up to me
and i'm angry like what's up you [ __ ]
ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] what's up and i'm just
like what
what the who the [ __ ] are you like yeah
don't talk to me like
i don't know you guys can talk to me
like that like i don't know you like
this
you know like i get where she's coming
from but it was just like all right
one type of girl at ralph's uh came from
that's a grocery store for those of you
not on the west coast um
i think she came i was at the self
checkout and she came up from behind she
worked there
she came from behind me and just gave me
a huge huge
scary luckily small but like oh my gosh
still i was like who is it who are you
who are i don't recognize these hands
yeah i would freak out yeah she said she
was like i love your videos and i was
like oh my god thank you thank you
looking for her you didn't have that
that like reaction to like something
like a horse
let her freeze i'm a freeze like she
does
wins it over oh my god that's crazy yeah
but she was super super sweet
caught me off guard for sure they get
really excited yeah which i love those i
love the ones that run up to like
can i hug you because from behind yes
yeah that's scary if you watch someone
in your house every day you think like
oh i know they're my friend
and i even do this like oh youtubers
that i watch that don't know me
i think we're friends like i and if i
saw them in real life i would
that my initial thought would be like
we're best friends with each other every
day
it's easy to get yourself in that mind
but yeah yeah we don't
we don't have the same relationship i
don't know your face i don't know i
don't know
yeah yeah it's a one-sided i don't know
who you are i love you but i'm sorry i
don't know you
yeah um okay so all right now that we
got the fun question out of the way i
just we just had some things to vent out
please stop asking me where david is i
don't [ __ ] know dude well
in real life p a lot of people aren't
bothered by this question i i guess
i don't know maybe i don't know why i'm
bothered by it but
because i brought it up before on jk
news and people like why are you
bothered to buy it but when people ask
where are you from
i get i'm like well first i go oh i'm
from i'm from santa barbara okay and
then they're like
no no where are you from and i'm like
california like i'm i don't i'm so
confused yeah and then they're like
no to like where your parents from i'm
like los angeles
oh that's an ethnicity thing i'm like it
makes i don't know why
it it bothers me i guess because it
makes me feel like i'm foreign i'm not
from here
like i should i shouldn't be here i'm
not supposed to be here
and i don't think they mean it that way
but when up until recently
i was really pissed at it like i was
like
i'm from here like what like
why and i guess people are just taught
to ask it that way but i didn't know
that like yeah
for me my mom always things that white
people need to stop doing
it's not just white people either yeah
it's it's any
all a lot of ethnicities but like mostly
white people right yeah
why do you even need to know that my mom
always taught me to ask what's your
ethnicity if you're asking that question
that's probably a better way to phrase
it yeah as soon as i get asked that
question
i'm just like i'm mexican there you go
yeah born and raised just give it to him
i guess at first i still get thrown off
because i'm like cause in la everyone's
kind of a transplant
right so yeah it's like oh i i assume
that you're not from here too
so because a lot of people are chicago
conversations like oh i'm from texas
like yeah
right i mean i don't probably sound that
much where they're going to know for
sure that i'm not from here
but it's a common question yes so then
when i go oh santa barbara and then they
don't stop
there i'm like it's a it's a race i
don't belong
you say i am not from here yeah yeah
it's the wording it's you should ask
like what's your ethnicity because then
i'm like well i'm filipino french
russian i've never been to any of those
countries
never been to the philippines never been
to russia never been to france yeah
so i'm not from there right yeah
ethnicity is where it's at it's weird
that's the word you gotta learn
people always get ethnicity and
nationality mixed up too but yeah i know
that one when i was a kid would piss me
off because i'd be like i'm american
nationality they're like no you're not
it's a nation i'm from bro
yes i am i was [ __ ] born here damn
so the next question is from larida
esmeralda
i always is that esmeralda is it
hunchback
yeah um and she asks do you believe we
look for partners that resemble our
parents dominant traits
yeah i think so i think people look for
things that are
comfortable and familiar with ourselves
without realizing it personally maybe
like even like physical a little bit too
like physical so for some people like
personality-wise for sure i know that a
lot of women
lean towards men that we kind of like
somewhat resemble
personality-wise their father yeah yeah
i didn't i didn't realize that until
recently when i came to terms with the
fact that i
i am understanding that my dad actually
was a bit emotionally unavailable even
though he was around so i i feel like a
lot of like a lot of the guys
that i date like oh they'll be good at
cooking like my dad they'll show their
love through cooking or something and
then
um they'll but they'll still be very
emotionally unavailable and i'm like oh
wait i never thought that i had a thing
with that
but i think it is like if you really
really like
get really deep down in when you're just
kind of looking for partners
unconsciously i think right but then
once you get to a point i think where
like nikki finally got to after being
in a horrible relationship where she was
like i'm wanting these values because
these are healthy values
then it's easier to maybe not do that
but i think a lot of us subconsciously
do
just kind of go for like what's familiar
yeah yeah
i lean more towards like like manlier
manly man because my dad
yeah um not saying that you know you
should never be
you know emotionally vulnerable and all
that [ __ ] like i am aware of that now
you should be
just want someone that will stand up to
you right yeah that will yell at me
well it's just what you're familiar with
just slap me a little bit um because i
i dated someone who was the opposite of
that ones and i realized after a few
months
in my mind this is really shitty so i'm
just like god you are so
soft you know like pardon me just like
he was very clingy to the point where if
i wanted to go downstairs and get food
he'd be like i'll go with you and i'm
just like oh
can you chill and then i realized that i
don't like people like that and i
like someone more like just have their
own [ __ ]
going on but very because my dad is very
like stoic you know got his own [ __ ]
going on but he's also very affectionate
in his own way and i i love you yeah
yeah yeah i like at a party um
being able to just split up and like go
talk to separate people i don't like
when the person's like
has to be right next to you the entire
time but they're not really
contributing to the conversation it's
like a shadow go talk to someone else
dude remember that one shitty dude that
dated for like four months and i
abandoned him in the middle of a road
trip
oh yeah we went to a club once to meet
up with my friends and my friends
they're like they're like everything
that dude ever wanted to be
um they're they're all like gang bangers
with like tattoos all over their scalps
and [ __ ] my gosh
and that's what he wanted to be like he
was like a poser online right
um and we were the club and the whole
time he literally just stood next to me
like this
oh this whole time i heard and then like
it got to the point
yeah like even when i went to go talk to
my friends he'll just come with me and
like hold on to my waist
and i'm like whatever happened to like
oh you know i'm a [ __ ]
thug blah blah whatever online that's
like independent thug
even my friend noticed and my friend
leaned down on me at the club and be
like
is this is this his first relationship
or something no no no that's what i know
i didn't even
notice it pulling it on so hard yeah i
didn't even notice it until she said
that i was like
oh [ __ ] this is really clingy dude
yeah i don't as you can tell well that's
just like
a negative kind of behavior but like for
do you feel like the guys that you date
kind of resemble your dad a little bit i
feel like
consciously subconsciously like um
and then like someone like almost
physically too like i love tattoos
and tattoos are a huge thing in my
family you know especially
my dad was the first in the family to
get all those tattoos my dad and steve
are
complete opposites physically like my
dad's a short filipino man
very dark the physical thing i think
there may be some personality things
but personality for sure 100 yeah theory
of the same
like in a good way like i mean my dad
had some
like not as great yeah traits like we
were talking about um
where like i felt like i always had to
win his love with like doing things
right not that that was true but like in
my mind it was um
because in his mind he was giving me
love by security and protection and
stuff and
i needed you know hugs and so uh
yeah like steve doesn't have any of that
but he
they are both very headstrong
um stubborn but like will stand up for
the right thing they can be [ __ ] if
they need to be
if it's for the right thing um yeah
uh they can be very petty and they could
be about revenge sometimes
i love petty steve but he seems great
okay can you picture steve doing this
because this isn't good at it um
so the neighbors have some dogs and the
dogs continually would pee
and poop on our la on on our front lawn
my parents house
and uh so my dad asked the neighbors hey
can you stop letting your dogs
piss and [ __ ] on our lawn because we're
trying to grow the grass out and
it's very clear we're trying to grow the
grass out and they're like oh yeah no
problem no problem
kept happening over and over again and
my dad just like
kind of like is respectful until a
boiling point and then he just gets so
[ __ ] mad so it happened one too many
times
and he walked out saw a bunch of dog
[ __ ] on the lawn
she took a shovel clean it no no they
don't have terrible
terrible dog that's how he would find it
is that like they would he would just
find dog [ __ ]
and so he uh took a shovel took the dog
[ __ ]
put it on their car oh the dog [ __ ]
i love that and then what happened to
that i love that they never [ __ ] on the
lawn again good great
good yeah so if you want to form healthy
habits
like pooping every day pooping every day
is very hard every day
um psychologically being in alignment
you know
maybe meditating so that you can be more
assertive and less
aggressive things uh maybe you should
download noom it's an app uh
they're our sponsor today thank you
shout out to noom um and noom
is really cool at like it it is i guess
a fitness app
in that sense that you can have fitness
goals and they have um
different exercises you can do and diets
and they make you more aware of like
what you're eating by keeping a food
journal
and so you can actually see your metrics
and what you're consuming per day
because a lot of people don't know a lot
of people don't keep a food journal they
don't even know what they're eating
every day
and a lot of times it's alarming you
don't know that you're consuming way
more than
you should or way too little depending
on what your habits are
so it doesn't just attack the symptoms
but your psychological
reasons for why you form your habits in
the first place and you kind of
it kind of helps you rewire those so
whether it's physical
like better self-care feeling more
confident clothing more energy
psychological which is like ability to
make healthy choices more easily or
understand your thought patterns better
or social where like if you're at a
party and you just grab
you know grab food right away or grab
drinks right away so that you
fit in it'll recognize those in your
life
noom is the habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses
noom doesn't tell you what to do and
what not to do it teaches you how to
look inside your own mind and make
better decisions for yourself numa is
one of the biggest and most accurate
food databases available that lets you
track meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance
so you don't have to change it all in
one day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noom
n-o-o-m dot com slash big mood what do
you have to lose
visit noom.com big mood
to start your trial today that's n o o m
dot com slash big mood you asked what do
you have to lose
what do i have to lose your old bra oh
you should toss that
you know what because uh third
third love does bras differently they
believe that every woman deserves to
feel comfortable and confident
every day with the right kind of support
third love
helps you do this and i'm currently
wearing my third love as of right now
salute sorry it is awesome i absolutely
love this bra because it fits perfectly
i've always had that
that issue with the cup being a little
too
big on the top the gap yeah that gap i
constantly had issues with that but not
until
i switched over to third love i don't
have that issue anymore it's a perfect
fit
and initially the way i found my perfect
fit is by
doing their fit finder quiz which helps
you identify your breast size and shape
and styles
that fit your body they have over 80 bra
sizes
but they will find out which one fits
you the best
and which one matters to you the most
and so perfect fit
promise every customer has 60 days to
wear it wash it put it to the test and
if you don't love it return it and third
love will wash and donate it to a woman
in need
you guys wash your bras uh yeah gina you
need to wash it
after this yeah and hands down it's the
most comfortable bra
you'll own i promise this because i
i'm telling you i love the most
comfortable bra i own it's great
i don't even like bras and i like this
one it's amazing so i actually have
three pairs they only gave me one for
free but i bought two more because i
absolutely love it
and so every bra is made for your
comfort with memory foam cups
no slip straps and smooth scratch free
band with a printed label so third love
knows there's a perfect bra for everyone
so
so right now they are offering our
listeners 15
off your first order go to thirdlove.com
big mood now
to find your perfect fitting bra and get
15 off your first purchase
that's thirdlove.com big mood for
fifteen percent off today
big move yeah yeah oh i just realized i
only said like my dad's bad quality or
something like steve's bag it was petty
revengeful i loved it yeah
putting dog [ __ ] on people's cars is the
right plus
all forever yeah and i thought about
about like the similarities that
casey has with my dad and my stepdad
actually
i didn't realize this until way later
but i
i realized how influential my stepdad
was in my life that i ended up picking
a man that kind of has similar qualities
as he does because my stepdad is a
really really quiet reserved kind of
person like very stoic
kind of man and that's definitely what
casey has been throughout our entire
relationship
very quiet like kept himself stoic
and um also very stubborn is another one
like they're both very very stubborn and
petty and very passive-aggressive
but also very hard-working like they're
they're very hard working and that's
something that
i realized well i'm like whoa and then
with my dad same thing like
really hard working i also found
similarities in
in likes so my dad loves movies like he
would always take me to the theater
like the movie theater growing up me and
my mom we would like every single
weekend we would be
in the movies watching the newest
release and that's so funny because
casey is obsessed with movies like the
movie theater is his sanctuary like he
absolutely love it so right now during
the pandemic
and we haven't been able to go to the
theater he's been hating it
[Music]
at home we wish we could all have
at-home movie theaters hey there's a
driving theater you should go
it's super fun well for him it's about
the the surround sound
darkness experience like it's it's
literally like like a whole process for
him i want to go to the boat one
oh yeah i've seen that but then i got
tickets
i do wonder how do you pee pee you just
jump out the side of the boat
you have to go before you get in i guess
yeah yeah yeah i plan on drinking on
that boat
like a peacock [ __ ] [ __ ] won't you
be on there for like an hour 30 or
something like they probably max out
your time right now okay
um all right so next question this was
kind of a this was kind of a heavy one
that i found really interesting um
this this comes from a miss visual here
it was a long one but i kind of
condensed it down she basically said
um i don't watch a lot of porn my
boyfriend watches porn regularly
one day i saw on his reddit uh account
uh i pushed the history button and it
was just all naked girls who looked
nothing like me and that scared me so uh
i
you know why do i why do i feel this way
and how can i stop it
i try to bring it up but i feel stupid
and i don't understand why i'm so
bothered he loves me he would never
cheat on me but the thought of it makes
me
disgusted with myself i don't look
anything like these girls i can never
live up to it it makes me insecure and
even question him
i only have eyes for him how can i learn
that porn isn't terrible
i feel like uh he fantasizes about those
girls or wishes he was with them
why don't i need porn to masturbate and
he feels like he or
why does he need it he's making women
like an object
and i want to be the only if if it is an
object i want to be the best and only
one
i want to be the object um why are women
treated as objects
and why are we so sexualized and men
aren't how can i fix my mentality
mentality about about it it's the whole
visual thing
but also the thing is i need like i want
her to understand that a lot of these
women in sex work it's empowering for
them
they don't feel like they are just an
object you know like this is something
that makes them feel strong they are
still a human being
um saying that your man just straight up
is just treating these porn stars
whatever like an object kind of
i don't know i feel like you're you're
putting your boyfriend down
well i mean it is kind of a objectify i
mean that's kind of what it is and
that's why
guys like it too because like they're
not emotionally attached to these women
like it's
it's literally just for physical visual
because for me when i think men are
objectifying women it's basically just
him saying like
well she's not even a [ __ ] human like
i can just treat her whatever she wants
whatever like i understand it's for a
porn thing it's a fantasy thing but when
i think objectifying women
as a man it's like um that's not even a
person
i don't see that as a human being
whatever it's just well some guys do
things yeah yeah which is shitty and i
don't
i don't i don't i i feel like you
shouldn't think that way just because he
watches porn i think that ends up
happening too once like that that
mentality of
objectifying women and i could be wrong
i don't know i'm not a guy but i think
it happens after
like a porn addiction develops and then
they are no longer able to see that
person
like as a human right right so it's just
like oh that's just something i can get
off to
and just not also like maybe the
boyfriend
sees you as a human like you're his
girlfriend he loves you he is
emotionally attached
you're a pers a whole person to him and
if he's objectifying this other girl
it's just
you know for the it's the physical
fantasy portion of it i also just want
it to be clear that it's it's completely
separate um
porn in a guy's mind and it is i don't
think you should compare
yourself to these women he i don't think
he wants
that over if he wanted something else he
would get it
let's get this clear what a man wants he
will get yeah and he's keeping you
yeah yeah he loves you it's not the same
also in our relationship i guess it's
kind of reverse like where i watch a lot
of porn
steve doesn't yeah um it's common i mean
i feel like i watch a lot of porn for a
female yeah
and some guys really don't and it's not
like a lot of points it's a cure
it's like once a week maybe like here
and there but none of those guys are
guys that i want to be with yeah like at
all like zero of the guys but it's just
a visual stimulation uh to get
going right and i don't want to be with
those guys
at all it's literally just a fantasy
just because we like what we're seeing
in porn doesn't mean we want it in real
life like
if i'm watching lumberjack porn i don't
want to date a lumberjack
so don't bring this into real life i
think the time
the moment where it is something to be
concerned about
is if it's affecting your actual
relationship your sex life your intimacy
if that's an issue then that is a clear
sign of a porn addiction honestly like
that
that as soon as it's unhealthy and it's
affecting people around you
that's when you need to go seek help so
if your boyfriend is not being as
intimate with you or he has trouble
getting it up because that's actually
another city he can never come
he's like porn yeah sick or you can
never yeah there's a difference between
a porn sick man
and then like a guy that maybe just like
like looks at it a few
you know a few times a month or
something and that's his little side gig
you know he's just been a little spin a
little self-love you know
on the weekend or something but for her
i feel like for you
if if he's not as like a sick addicted
man
and like he's really good too your sex
life is fine he cuddles you he's
emotionally available he's a great
person to you
this might have to be something that
you're just gonna have to work on
yourself
or maybe it's better like a kind of out
of sight out of mind like
i don't i really don't know how like how
to give this girl any help because i
understand her position like i
understand
it sucks to think about your guy like
lusting after like your
feelings are not wrong right yeah
they're not wrong at all it's just like
it's one of those things like
what can you really do i just feel like
it's in
you need to just just understand it's in
such a different plane like nikki said
like this is
just sex whatever jacking off fine but
who he wants to be with is who he chose
to be with and that's you
you know he didn't want to just do with
you for your body parts yeah
right and i yeah he looks at girls that
may not look like you but it doesn't
necessarily mean he's gonna
cheat on you or you know it's that he
wants yeah that's fantasy world yeah
that's fantasy world
i think jason mama is hot but i'm dating
people who looks nothing like you
same i mean literally same look at my
husband furthest thing away from
jason yeah i feel like also it's a
little bit healthy too for a guy to
because i mean the way guys are wired
like
and all throughout history like their
their thing is to spread their seed
right variety like it's it's in
their genes to want variety to want to
[ __ ] everything they can to keep the
human population going so him just kind
of
getting rid of that little bit of his
caveman self right
through seeing a little bit of variety
on camera but i mean there's certain
things that are [ __ ] creepy like if
he's paying cam girls and there's almost
like oh yeah
there's all this there's like
interaction or like there's there's
emotional
attacks it's a fine line so i mean as
long as he's not doing [ __ ] to cross the
line i mean you guys that's the
discussion you need to have is to set
boundaries and see
yeah how far is that he's like standing
some
a certain porn star falling in love with
one girl and it's like
thousands of pictures of you know emily
ratachowski or something i'd be like
okay you're getting a little obsessed
with this person and this
feels like an emotional yeah right
but if it's just like just watching porn
and just getting off or he likes
uh hot oh she also mentioned that he
would like
like instagram models or porn stars
pictures on instagram
i think that's the discussion of
boundaries there hold on now you're
you're getting out of our now you're
getting out of your private
zone and now it's being publicly
displayed and that me as your girlfriend
i feel offended by that that's a
discussion that needs to be yeah
i agree with that that's a that's a line
yeah you can discuss like boundaries and
and like things yeah i mean yeah yeah
because i hate when if that discussion
comes up then
easily it could be like that
conversation could be twisted and like
well why are you so jealous why are you
so insecure like now i can't follow
girls i know what his response is
because if he's gonna be like
okay so if your man is gonna be kind of
emotionally
receptive and like understanding and
like look i'm sorry like i
but this is not this has nothing to do
with how i feel about you
blah blah blah like what things can i
maybe do
to help you feel more comfortable or
whatever just in some way to show at
least respect for your feelings that i
would be like
you know then you can maybe think about
like is this really that big of an issue
but if he starts [ __ ] gaslighting you
or being shitty about it then i don't
know girlfriend maybe he's not worth it
yeah yeah i used to actually think that
liking a photo
didn't i never understood why people
would get upset that their man liked
another girl's photos
um but that's because i come from a
different side of instagram you know
like if dude likes my photos i'm like
yeah whatever that's like one amongst
thousands or like
if i were to like a guy's photos it's
not because
hey you know i mean i'm [ __ ] like
like shia labeouf like if he saw the
things i wrote and liked about him on
the internet
he would probably be like this is a
stalker yeah so it's like i mean do you
as a female do you not like lust over
any man yeah
less over movie stars like it's it's
like it's still so it's removed from
your real life like i turned around and
i would see my boyfriend and be like oh
but i really actually love you like
this is where i'm staying it's not about
actually shia i'm not gonna
yeah get him i've i've heard stories of
where like
a couple will be watching tv like a
movie or something and the guy would be
like wow she's hot and the girl will get
legit angry
like why are you angry like do you think
you can literally go out there and pull
a movie star [ __ ]
you know like but also do you never have
those thoughts yourself exactly like
don't have a double standard
like you never think about a place of
insecurity because they're like
they themselves are feeling like they're
just not enough and that's really the
root of it all yeah and i don't think
that's true
that's a lie that you tell to yourself
that you're not good enough
but circling back to what i said i used
to think that i just never understood
why like why are you getting upset
because he'd like some random [ __ ]
photos
and then i realized people outside of
entertainment or have a following have a
way different dynamic like
they have a different uh relationship
with social media exactly
because for me it's just whatever but
for other people i can see it now
because uh
i feel like if he were to like this
girl's photos over and over and over and
over and over again it's
him inserting herself into her life it's
almost like he wants to be seen
kind of and it's like a weird little
also if you were dating someone
and they were watching porn with the
same porn star in it over and over and
then they were going on instagram and
liking her pictures yeah
i don't know i guess it would be a
little different to me because not now
like you said like tiff said um
it's now gone past the point of being
like a nameless face
ejaculate usually like after i orgasm
i'm done like i don't
i don't even like watching it
i'm disgusting why did i do it
gross i do not do this that's not me
yeah
but then to go afterwards and be like i
wonder what this guy's insta is oh [ __ ]
look at all these shirtless pics and
then go like liking all of his stuff
that's kind of
a little more yeah it's like he's
mentally removed from the relationship a
little bit
yeah it is more intimate yeah it is it
is more intimate but i also feel like i
wouldn't be
as bothered and or threatened if it was
someone that was like
she has like two million followers you
know dude i recently saw the thing that
you retweeted
on twitter how this girl she posted like
some like uh
really sexual kind of photo or not
sexual
yeah her outfit was just very revealing
yeah that's what it is
and she looked great by the way and so
this girl girl
yeah this girl she ends up messaging the
girl who posted the photo and saying
can you block this and delete your
photos
this is my boyfriend and he keeps liking
your [ __ ] and you need a
you need to block him like okay do not
be that girl
ever ever no you need to have a
conversation with your man
why the [ __ ] are you hitting up the girl
like she doesn't even know
she's just existing and thriving and
being sexy
that is not her problem no dude that
that like made my skin crawl because i'm
like
why are you bringing it low value female
behavior exactly and it was crazy
because she was she was like not only
did she say hey blocks person she said
delete your photo
yeah you want me to delete what i posted
on my social media no
because your boyfriend can't control it
exactly yeah finger liking
my photo because you guys have issues in
your relationship and then the girl the
hot girl responded saying uh this is not
my problem like
i have nothing to do with this and then
the crazy girl straight up goes why are
you defending him are you [ __ ] him
i hope you [ __ ] died
that guy is trapped he's a prisoner yeah
not just that but i don't fully blame
the girlfriend because obviously he's
done
enough in the relationship oh he's
pretty curious security [ __ ]
manipulation
so i'm like they're taking her through
the ringer yeah we don't know any of
these people we don't know them but in
other traumas
that's extremely unhealthy behavior it's
very unhealthy it comes at
the root is like it's it's with her she
has to understand like this has nothing
to do with you like
i porn or hot girls online
do you have to think of it as a they're
so occupied with hundreds and thousands
of millions of fans they're never gonna
[ __ ] notice you're a dude yeah it's
a spectrum thing too it's like just just
observe and really try to be objective
about
is it too much yeah or is it is it like
just a little bit and it's like
because for guys it's gonna be hard to
be like oh i'm never gonna date a guy
that
ever looks at porn ever yeah it's like
girl that's like
[ __ ] one percent of men probably or
you're asking them to be dishonest
yeah you're asking them to lie and hide
it and then it creates more yeah that's
why to me
it really just boils down to how is it
affecting you and your relationship your
intimacy and if it is
affecting it then that's a problem how
does he respond to you bringing up that
problem but don't be a [ __ ] and crazy
when you bring it up yeah talk
communicate calmly yes it's hard i know
yeah i just thought of this story but
i feel like the story of like we'll talk
about it some other time because right
now
i'm so hungry about some some food so
hungry should we get food should we make
some food please please make this only
we have the ingredients
fresh food right can you make it really
fast too hello
that was how cute all right guys hello
fresh offers
so many recipes to choose from each week
to help you break out of your recipe
right that is me i swear to god like
once i learn how to cook a dish
like i just buy the same food at the
grocery store and i just cook the same
thing over and over until i'm tired of
it because i don't have a creative mind
when it comes to food
but hello fresh makes it easy to try new
stuff because they just it just shows up
at your door it's like hey make this
cute little dish that you never would
have made with couscous and lemon
and i'm like oh okay thank you it's so
much easier to have someone like kind of
spoon feed me like
new ways to cook hellofresh cuts out
stressful meal planning and grocery
store trips so you can enjoy cooking and
get dinner on the table in just about 30
minutes
or even 20 minutes with some of their
quick recipe options
the pre-portioned ingredients means
there's less prep and less food waste
and also hellofresh has donated over 2.5
million meals to charity in 2019
like how do they even afford that that's
crazy 2.5 million meals
that's dope one of my favorites um we
always talk about the
balsamic fig balsamic pork but i also
love the chicken breast one where you
kind of like cover a chicken breast
with uh sour cream and then you like
pack on the panko bread crumbs and the
parmesan cheese and i
would have never thought to do that and
you bake it it comes out really good
so it's a super fast way to get like
oven fried baked
chicken kind of i don't know it's it's
healthier baked yes it's pretty good
it just lets it makes you look like you
know what you're doing yeah yeah
sometimes you make stuff and you're like
i made it yeah right i
did that especially i hate cooking but
they make it so fun to cook and the the
pre-portioned ingredients just makes it
so easy where i feel like i'm a pro and
yeah
to try america's number one meal kit go
to hellofresh.com
slash 80 big mood and use code 80 big
mood
to get a total of 80 off your first
month including free shipping on your
first
box with additional restrictions uh
visit hellofresh.com for more details
again that's hellofresh.com eight zero
big mood and use code eight zero big
mood and get a total of eighty dollars
off your first month
including free shipping on your first
box additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for more details
eighty dollars what's 80 dollars dull
hairs
that's a lot of doll hairs there's a lot
of doll hairs that's just a lot all here
um our next question comes from cassie
what up cassie fine as [ __ ] by the way
hey we got a fine girl's phone oh
something i can't see the singer though
i'm sure this cast is hot as [ __ ] um
cassie oh god i related to this one when
i read this one uh
she said i was recently having sex with
my mans and we usually have really good
sex good for you
yeah but for some reason it just wasn't
working this last time we tried multiple
times and i felt like i was hurting him
or he looked bored
at the end i was turned off and i felt
not sexy how do you guys handle
off days like this just don't take it
personally i guess
yeah if it happens if it becomes a
pattern then yeah
i would bring it up but if it's just a
one-off
every so often like every once in a
while yeah
because you never know what the dude's
going through yeah sometimes i've been
like that
and i love sex but you know it's just
like
you can't expect perfection every time
and you can't control your emotions like
exactly
you had a something bad that happened
earlier in the day and you just can't
let it go like
maybe you didn't realize you were having
a bad day until you have to do something
that requires intimacy which
then you're like yeah your subconscious
is like wait we're not ready yet
yeah exactly and then because i've had
those days too and then my body's like
it's not happening yeah it's just not
yeah and your brain's like wait but i
want it to happen but your body's like
nah we're shut down yep don't take it
personally i mean i've had days where
it's just like
i will be riding him and be like and
it's great he's like but i'm kind of
tired can we
just stop yeah that's natural i mean you
have to actually be willing to accept
failure in
every area of life you know i think it's
because no one talks about it like so
you think that it doesn't happen to
everybody else it does
so it's embarrassing when it was like oh
no i'm like a weirdo like i i
i don't want to be the lame one saying
that
we're not having sex anymore but it
actually it's very common for
people to get tired or have a cramp
sometimes like you get a cramp and
you're just like i can't go
i can't keep going um sometimes have you
ever gotten like an
air bubble in your yes yes and they like
hurt
yeah i've had to stop before because it
just hurts yeah like i don't know what's
happening you're hitting it the wrong
way
something i don't know but i'm not going
to come and [ __ ] do we have an answer
for that because sometimes it just
happens
it's annoying take a break i think
different times of the month too like
your vagina
like your cervix survives lower yeah
i don't know like your juices are
different so it'll feel different and
like like our bodies are not the same
every single day of the month i mean i
feel like guys dicks are pretty much the
same all the time but then their moods
and other things affect it like the
hardness could change
yeah yeah but for us like our like
literally our physiology
changes constantly did you know that i
didn't know this earlier but um
your voice actually changes depending on
what week of the month you're you're in
your cycle oh i haven't noticed yeah it
gets i can't remember exactly what it is
but i think it's
it's lower when you're ovulating and
then it gets higher sexier
yeah whoa
and i am ovulating this week so many
[Applause]
last month's video uh from yeah who
knows
yeah i've you guys i mean it's happened
to everyone you know and i remember
feeling that way too and i'm just like
is there something wrong with you yeah
because you never see it like you don't
see other people's sex lives no one
talks about it
it's not in porn so you're not gonna
ever
you're going to feel like you're some
odd man out i think she's afraid that
like oh this is
this is what he's going to remember now
that i suck at sex or like this is the
beginning of the end of our sex life or
something because like it's the first
time that it didn't
true you're worried i'm saying it
becomes a pattern
maybe you can bring it up and like just
have a frank discussion
and an open you know honest vulnerable
discussion but
i had a really shitty sex one time where
a guy that i was dating came over
and then um he was like oh do you want
to pull your toy and i was like okay
so i pulled out a toy and i started
using it and it died
and then i was like [ __ ] so i kind of
tossed it and then i got in my drawer
and i pulled out another one and we're
going again
and i used it and then that that one
died too well
so i threw it i threw it to the side and
i kid you not i got the third one out
and the third
whole arsenal in our house i went to the
kitchen cabinet i got the 16th one
no i was i had been single for a while
and i haven't i
i worked with this brand right so i they
sent me their entire collection so i had
the entire thing
and i had used she gave me one of them
so i'd use their entire collection but i
just hadn't charged any of them in a
while so i think it just they all kind
of have they were all in their last leg
of life but yeah so i pulled out three
in a row that all died and he got soft
and he was just like
what the [ __ ] yeah i was like and but
but that it's like an embarrassing it
didn't work like we stopped having sex
you know we didn't have sex again that
day and just sit
but then it's like everyone has these
things like i think we just need to talk
about it more like sometimes
sex fails and it's okay it happens to
girls and it happens to guys too that's
why having a girl chat
helps so much yeah like that's when we
started was by
sharing when you realize you're not the
only yes it helps a lot
it really does because we think we're
like just so
[ __ ] up or something yeah yeah because
initially like i
like with gina i'm like am i broken
i feel broken when he can't get it up or
when i can't get in the mood even though
i really want to so i feel like i'm
broken both times and then it's really
important to have that
like empathetic like nurturing kind of
conversation when like when the other
partner's not really into it and just
being like hey it's cool like
no worries like we could just handle it
some other time no big deal because as
soon as you make it a big deal then
that's when it just
really makes it yeah ten times worse it
emphasizes
it for the next time sometimes you gotta
just true because it creates trauma
yeah the next time you're afraid that's
going to happen and then it happens
again and then
it's trauma it's just not a good time or
like you keep
thinking about it during sex and it
kills the movie it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
if you let it get to your head too much
you just gotta be like well that one
didn't work out maybe you can laugh
about it
instead of [ __ ] don't dig yourself a
hole
exactly don't worry it happens to
everyone you're fine yeah
talk about it i bring it up right away
like hey say something wrong and then
it'll just be like
no i'm just having a bad day you know
just just communicate yeah
the next question is from alicia likes
pink ah cute
have you ever been the cause of a
breakup like someone else breaking up
i saw this in two ways like other people
breaking up or you
are the cause of the reason why you guys
broke up oh
i see i thought i thought it was like
the third person coming in like i've had
a third person issue before
yeah i have this crazy chick dude like i
have a friend who lives up in
in washington super dope dude started
dating this girl
and for some reason she just hyper
aggroed on me
like just super aggro on me oh and um so
he's like a photographer he shot me
before
and i don't know what conversation they
had before that but she suddenly started
getting hyper focused on me
when like i said he lives far away we
only chat like once every few months
like yo dude what's up how you doing you
know because we're close but we don't
talk all the time
and then it just it escalated within
like two months it escalated from
hey my girlfriend said i can't talk to
you anymore
i'm very understanding i'm like yeah
that's fine whatever you know like i
post [ __ ] hoe photos online
yeah you know it's fine so i'm totally
okay with it i don't get offended
and then i went to hey my girlfriend
told me to block you
totally okay hey my girlfriend might
message you
oh and i'm just like okay what
like was he obsessed with that yeah that
sounds like this
no how do you know no because like
because he and i were close friends you
know okay but like never
like talking every day or whatever just
like hey i heard you know something
happened family are you okay
just like that she let the seed grow a
little too much yeah yeah
um and he was doing whatever he can like
dude like there's something going on you
know i don't want to talk to her
um and then she messaged me saying hi
i'm a friend of let's call him ryan i'm
a friend of ryan
and he would just like me to tell you
that he doesn't find any value in your
friendship anymore and he doesn't want
to be
what okay she's like and i'm just like
okay
you're like sure that's fine and then
so i sent him a screenshot i was like
aaron this is [ __ ] weird but this is
your relationship
i don't care i'm not gonna interact i'm
fine as a friend i would be like dude
what are you doing with this i did i
why are you so desperate to stay with me
she was a stripper so maybe she was just
dope and he said the sex was great
um and then so like i did tell him i'm
like this is by the way this is kind of
[ __ ] weird it's your first year
together
and she's like super crazy on me and i
i didn't do anything and then like four
weeks four or five weeks later it's um
in the middle of the night i get a
message saying you win
from her i was like what the [ __ ] whoa
bro so i finally interacted i was like
what are you talking about like you
wouldn't want i don't want your man
yeah i don't want your dude she goes he
clearly wants to be friends with you
more than he wants to be with me so you
win you can have him so dumb and i'm
like i didn't even know i was in a
competition
you know and then she was just like i
clearly he wants to be with you more and
i'm just like what the [ __ ] i think it's
it finally he told me he's like i ended
it because i just felt like she was
being
too [ __ ] crazy yeah and that and she
took it as
well because i was still gonna be
friends with gina yeah like that was
twisted she couldn't she couldn't accept
that it was because she was crazy she
was not living in reality
yeah that's a little nuts that was a
little nuts
have you guys ever had a problem where
like a couple or a girl came to you like
what the [ __ ]
for no reason um i've i've been the girl
being like
hey did this happen but not in a way
that was attacking the girl
it was just like i felt like i was being
lied to and this happened
twice so i have a pattern with [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you broke it yeah exactly i broke it um
but yeah
it happened in uh like two relationships
ago um
through myspace like i i had this
feeling and then i he left his account
open on my on my computer of his myspace
profile
and i saw messages to her and i was like
i knew it and it was all about her like
like oh you just got out of the shower
oh can i come over like type of things
and then
she was like don't you have a girlfriend
and he was like
oh she's always busy blah blah blah i'm
always trying to hang out he's like i'm
too busy blah blah blah
anyway so that was that guy and then the
other and so i reached out to her just
like thank you like this is so nice of
you and also i'm gonna dump him
um and then the other guy uh swore up
and down
on his life that he was not going
anywhere near this is a worker
yes i remember yeah and um and he's like
i wouldn't touch her with a ten foot
pull blah blah blah here's all the
reasons why
found out he spent the night at her
house and then i just reached out and i
was like
hey you don't know me i don't know you
um i just need to know because if i'm
being lied to you i just wanna let this
person go
like i just need to like the release
like please let me free
and um and she was like yeah like we did
do stuff
like i'm so sorry i didn't know right
like i thought you guys are
kind of the right also that's the right
way to go about it too it's not like hey
you [ __ ] [ __ ] are you sleeping with
me
hey i just i'm curious are you with this
guy because he's also messing with me so
like what's up
you know like that crazy girl i tried
like you know like i try not to interact
much because i don't want to affect your
relationship but i did try to reason
with her and i was like hey
listen woman a woman this doesn't look
good you know like i didn't do anything
you know and i'm i'm telling you that
right now but she's couldn't accept it
but when chicks are cool like hey yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] cool like i remember
when i found out my ex cheated on me um
that girl
and i exchanged numbers
yeah it was you chris tuckered him is
that what happened
chris tucker no not chris what was his
name john tucker whatever must die yeah
so that girl's cousin happened to be
this girl that i went to middle school
with who i haven't spoken to in like 10
years
oh and that that middle school girl hit
me up she's like hey is this your
boyfriend i'm like yeah she goes
he's been going out with my cousin and
this is like a girl from my hometown
because i guess she should be good for
that girl yeah like hey shout out to kim
dude you're the chef
she's got eyes and ears everywhere yeah
yeah so um she was i was like all right
give me that girl's phone number you
know because that girl didn't know
that he had a good yeah it's not her
fault i'm just gonna attack her yeah
and then so we got a phone call together
three-way called him
[Laughter]
so i i spoke to him i was like hey so do
you know who this girl is um her like
and then her name was vicky and he was
just like oh yeah you know she's some
girl
you know that was i don't know i know
she was online you know for her to have
to hear that
yeah that's so heartbreaking and then i
was like so sorry it's awesome that he
got caught
to have to hear that though because i
had the same thing happened to me i
heard
i had to overhear him yeah yeah so what
happened so
but before we called him like we were
going through our timelines i was like
he went to san diego this weekend she's
like no he was with me this weekend
yeah so we went through our timelines
and realized he was doing this for about
a month or two
and then um so we call him and then he's
like oh yeah this girl i was filming a
a wedding and she was there and i was
like did you hang out there did you kiss
her he goes
no not a kid's like you know like uh
like a you know like french people
goodbye like and that's it on the cheek
cheek to cheek and she
blew up she was like she started
screaming she's like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] liar
it's me vicki i'm on the phone right now
you piece of [ __ ] and she was dope she's
like you don't deserve gina she's a good
[ __ ] person you [ __ ] did this you
piece of [ __ ] you don't deserve [ __ ]
like she was dope yeah awesome and he
was just like
and then i was like what do you have to
say like have you ever been so angry yes
that you just are calm yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like i was just oh
yeah and then even the fly in the room
just sat down yeah
oxygen
so he's just like all right you caught
me and this is when i
was working my day job i
told my boss i was like i need to go
because i this is
you you don't want me here today yeah
and i drove 40 minutes have you ever
been so angry you drove with your music
on yeah yes i drove two and a half hours
once
oh yeah silence that's right silence in
silence
chain smoking cigarettes yeah yes this
is when i was heavy smoking
yeah yeah and okay so forgive me but i
was 19 years old
i went to his place his best friend you
know he told his
best friend what happened his best
friend knew at 19 years old i'm [ __ ]
crazy kind of
right so his best friend called me up
he's like hey listen you know like
just calm down bruh shut the [ __ ] up
i may have taken i allegedly took a base
no
golf club to the wall
allegedly allegedly would have done
her mind she did this and then there was
a physical hole in the wall but
we don't know what i don't know where
that came from you can't prove it
there's no cameras
and this is how i knew that i was a very
rational person still because
because like i said he's a cameraman
editor i could have just dumped all that
wedding footage into his fish tank
and all his gear his laptop and
everything the livelihood
me rational see 19 years old insane but
still smart
didn't want to get sued oh i was gonna
be like you didn't want to ruin those
people's weddings
then being happy no one can have them if
i can
not a good person let's preserve this
love right not a good person i just
don't want to get sued
um yeah so that's what happened there um
you know it's like allegedly though it
was yeah allegedly it's really cool
hearing those stories of the girls being
dope as [ __ ]
because there is the other like on the
other side
is the the i can see your man
girl i saw this tick tock recently of
this girl saying that she was like you
know
you know you know who you are the ones
that i consider men if i want to
well you think that you're all this like
bad ass [ __ ] that you could just steal
anyone that you want but in reality
if you do get your girls man all right
that girls man that girl's man is
because he was looking for
an easy [ __ ] and you were an easy [ __ ]
and that's the reason why you got him
yeah so true
by the way if you can steal my man i
don't want my man exactly yeah you're
stealing low quality
you're stealing local yeah
congratulations if he's gonna cheat he's
local
exactly my man would never be stolen so
we both lose
yeah okay so i don't like imagine she
did ufo actually yeah you're doing us a
favor i don't even understand the
competition part i've never
tried to ever compete for a man before
ever they probably don't feel
worthy enough so they need to seek
validation let me say this
i do think men kind of prime us to
compete and and some toxic guys will do
this thing where i don't know if it's
called triangulation or whatever but
like they'll kind of like put uh the
image of another woman in your mind so
that you just kind of subconsciously
want to start competing for his
attention for that woman like if you're
dating a new guy and he's just like
oh yeah and then you know this this
waitress blah blah like i see her every
week and
like he'll just plant little tiny things
for you to be like well
i want him to pick me not her so let me
know what my ex did with his ex
how he kept bringing her up yeah there's
kind of a thing that men
like that manipulative men will do or
they'll kind of like
put another woman in your mind to make
you think oh
well who's this woman and like do i need
to compete yeah i think probably women
do that
to other guys too just piss me off that
that shitty dude that i dated briefly he
kept on saying like um i didn't realize
this was manipulation until like
um like whenever we get into an argument
he'll be like sometimes like you just
make me want to go back to my ex because
she just never
yeah that's i have no idea if anyone
ever [ __ ] says that to you you better
run
yeah run go back to your ex cause that
was yeah she'll take you back
and then finally it got to the point
where like oh you don't want to go to my
back to my hometown with me to visit my
family i guess i'll just hang out with
my ex and it got to the point where i'm
like
i don't give a [ __ ] go ahead and then
that's when they're like
wait oh no what do you mean you don't
give a [ __ ] and then that's when he
started crying
and i didn't even know that manipulation
yeah i didn't notice manipulation until
like i was on a reddit
post about like how do people manipulate
and this girl posted like oh he would
say that he's going to hang out
with xbo about to get me to and then to
try harder
yeah and then i was like oh my god i had
no idea that was
manipulation and i responded i was like
wait
that's one of the tactics yeah yeah dude
i had no clue
disgusting don't ever let that [ __ ]
slide with the question was have you
ever been the
reason why someone broke up um you broke
up i've never been the reason why
someone broke up but
on the jealous scene though um like one
of steve's exes
uh like i was really mean to me all the
time and like
and i didn't know we i we knew each
other and i always tried to be her
friend and like
i was in a long-term relationship i love
my boyfriend like
if i'm in a relationship i only have
eyes for that person
so like i i'm not trying to steal your
man okay like we're not
competing or whatever but she was always
just like really
rude um and like just kind of fake nice
when she was nice but like
it's like rude and backstabby um and i
was like why did she hate me so much
then when steve and i started dating i
finally found out
that she always kind of thought like
maybe there's a thing
and there was never a thing swear to god
i bet you until this time
she's at your marriage she's like yeah
yeah but i will say like good on her for
being able to like college
exactly something happened with both me
and casey's exes
they both had this weird jealousy for
like
so casey's ex had this weird jealousy
towards me because like there was a
there were a few times where we're in
the same room and i didn't even know
casey i didn't even know casey like we
didn't even like nothing
it was weird but they somehow picked up
on i wonder if people can sense like an
unconscious attraction like something
for her it was then
like she had that whatever feeling which
was totally false at least on my end
like don't be shitty to me i'm not
i'm not flirting with your dude maybe
whatever maybe she just saw a little
look now i was gonna say
um so she he was in the shower one time
and he left his laptop open and
apparently
my facebook profile was on there and
that was her proof
even though facebook was like a thing
everyone was on back then and also
steve and i used to unsubscribe from
each other all the time like that was
our like inside joke yeah like in our
group it would be like
well i'm unsubscribing from your channel
but um yeah but also steve's like a
super loyal person and
i watched them in a relationship and was
like wow like he's so
good to her like he's like such a good
boyfriend
i would never in a million years think
he was attracted to anyone else
yeah but she like yeah she was and she
was like that with other girls too not
just me
but yeah i don't know if she was like
that with other girls or like my
situation i don't know she was like that
with others but for sure she would
always give me the stank eye and i'm
like
i don't even know you people yeah i
literally don't know who you are
man we're going to plant so much
paranoia of now with this episode oh
well
deal with it yourself because this
episode's over i'm just kidding
um okay so i mean that's all the time we
have for today thank you guys for asking
us
questions in a big ass
make sure you guys follow us on
instagram at big mood girls because
we're always prompting to ask questions
and you guys can
ask us for a chance to have a shout out
thanks for asking thanks for giving us
something to talk about
talk to us message us uh make sure you
guys
like the video subscribe give us five
stars on itunes spotify i don't know how
spotify works but uh give us
give us give us that because we need it
thank you guys so much for watching
big ask mood which by the way shout out
to
our follower davita because she's the
one who came up with this name we love
you thank you
you will not get royalties off of this
um
thank you make sure you guys follow us
on instagram at
big mood girls because we will be asking
you guys to ask us questions for a
chance of a shout out
uh and make sure you guys like the video
subscribe give us five stars on
itunes and spotify because we need it we
love it
we thrive off of it we'll see you guys
next week we love you
peace out